みなさん、
ここのドーゲン
は
、他のどのビデオにもうまく適合しないいくつかの発表をしたかったので、
日本の音声学のナンバーワンは
、私の日本のコメディコンテンツを延期することにした最初の応答のために素晴らしいサポートに感謝します
少し
集中して、これらの日本語の音声学のレッスンをプッシュすることに集中してください。
来週の月曜日にドゴンのビデオをリリースし、その1
週間後に日本の音声学のレッスン
をリリースするのではなく、今週金曜日または土曜日に2番目の
日本語の音声学のビデオを
リリースします。 来週の同じ時間に
、典型的なドゴンコメディ
コンテンツが間にない場合、これが私の部分で大きな謎である場合は、
ポイント2の
パトレオンを教えてください。エピソード4とBeyond of
Japanese Phoneticsは
、私が使用しているパトレオン専用になることを明確にしたいと思います。
理想的な世界での最終的なキャリア移行のための財政的基盤を作成するためのシリーズ
私は3つの音声
日本語vをリリースします ideosは1週間で
コンテンツをすばやくパッケージ化し、
完成したプログラムを豆腐のような場所にアップロードし
ます。ユーザーは完成した
プログラムを教科書の価格で
さらに理想的な世界で購入でき
ます。シリーズ全体をYouTubeで無料でホストします
が、 チャネルはまだ非常に
小さいので、フルタイムで作業
して出力を高速化する唯一の方法は
、自分用のプラットフォームを作成し
、事前に設定された所定の
財務しきい値に達したらそのプラットフォームに切り替えることです。
つまり、月額10ドルのパトレオンです。 価格
を下げて総収入を増やすことができればプレミアムです
が、より多くの
視聴者を獲得するには間違いなく価格を下げる
ので
、より低い価格でサインアップする
と思われる場合はお知らせください。お知らせください。
数字を計算してみてください。
そうすれば純利益が得られると思われる場合
は、すでに支払った人のシリーズ発行の払い戻しの3つの価格を下げることができます。
d
こうすればシリーズをもっと早く押し出すこと
ができると思うので、みんなにとって有益だと思います。
ポイント3のInstagramこれ
はしばらくの間ビデオの説明にありました
が、ビデオで言及したことはありません。
私がよく知っている日本の誤解と呼ばれるパトレオンのシリーズをやっているのかわかりませんが、
最近、
外国人が日本語を学ぶときにしばしば失敗する言葉を発音
しました。これは、日本の音声学の最初のエピソードで行ったものと非常によく似ています。
完全に無料で、
日本語を補足します。 音声学がとても上手な
ので、
日本人の学習者全員にチェックして
みることを強くお勧めします。Instagramcomm/Dogon先生Dogon
先生ポイント4番目のサブタイトルイベント
なしという名前のとても親切なyoutuberiam
が私のビデオに日本語のサブタイトルを追加し始めました。
まだ初期段階で、ほとんどの
動画はまだ完成していませんが、
彼の努力から判断すると、
ほとんどの動画はフィニになると
思います。
ちなみに、彼は歯科医シリーズ全体をすでに終えており、その後
、両方のコメディー日本語レッスンを承認したばかり
なので、
最近のすべてのビデオに、数日以内に日本語の字幕が付いていることを期待して
ください。
CCボタンを押す必要がありますこれは
私の聴衆の多くの日本人学習者が
要求している機能ですので、ベントIAMがなく
、彼のチャンネルに向かい
、彼の懸命な努力に感謝します。
それだけです 現在
、日本の音声学のエピソード2を録画しているので、
すべてがうまくいけば、すぐにアップし
て、ジャンプカットを減らして撮影する
予定ですが、すばらしいサポートのおかげで、再びどうなるかを見ていきます。